hello and welcome back to another
episode of the DIY guide.net all right
today we're going to be showing you how
to reprogram your key fob for your older
Subaru uh this is a 2000 Outback this
procedure is going to work on a legacy
or Outback 99 to 2004 a Forester 01 to
2004 and your Impreza 02 to 04 now the
colored button remote like this here is
for an 02 to 04 if you had just the gray
buttons that's a 99 to 01 uh the remotes
are interchangeable I believe I know I
programmed a colored remote like this to
an older Subaru not for the year that
it's supposed to be so we're going to
program this colored remote which is the
O2 to4 to a 2000
Outback so if you have a 2005 and newer
Subaru you want to click the link in the
bottom right hand
corner so let's get
started all right so we're going to get
in the vehicle in the driver's seat want
to make sure that all the doors your
trunk or tailgate are closed you want to
make sure that they're all in the
unlocked position
so next to start we're going to open and
close the driver's door after we close
the door we're going to take the key
Stick in ignition go from the off
position to the on position and back to
the off position 10 times now we don't
want to start the vehicle we just want
the dash lights to come on we need to do
this very quickly uh at which time if we
do it correctly in in the amount of time
the horn is going to honk one time to
let you know you started the programming
mode once you hear that horn honk we're
going to open and close the driver's
door once you close the the door you're
going to press any button on the key fob
you want to program at which time you're
going to hear the horn honk twice you
want to program additional remotes
you're going to open and close the
driver's door and press any button on
the next remote you want to program you
can program up to four remotes once
you're done programming remotes you're
going to pull the key from the ignition
at which time the horn will honk three
times to let you know you've done it
successfully so let's get started
so we heard it beep once we'll open and
close the
door press any button on the fob we want
to
program we heard it beep twice so we're
only programming this one so we're going
to pull the key from the if you're going
to program another one you'd open the
door and press the button on the next
remote to be programmed so we should
hear the horn honk three
times so now that we heard the horn honk
three times this should be programmed
successfully to this car
we're going to go wait a couple seconds
and then we'll go ahead and test it so
we'll press the lock button
first as you could hear it locked uh you
can also see the security light on the
dash hopefully blinking away we'll go
ahead and press
unlock and it functions as it should so
we just showed you how to successfully
program a key fob for a older
Subaru thanks for watching another
episode of the DIY guide.net net he just
finished building you the Subscribe
button click that to get our latest DIY
fixes delivered right to you he just
finished building you the what's next
button you can click that and we help
you figure out what you want to fix next
you can also click the link in the
description which take you to our
website for a full write up